2020 first episode fam Jews new year new
me me
brav [ __ ] you know annoys me what it's
always the same me it's just about to
save have new year save me it's lazy to
say the same [ __ ] me always always
I'm no different from cuz I'm wise
enough I'm trying to I'm always trying
to save money but my saving money
doesn't work but you know how speak in
you know when I said I but the holiday
take me every day and I'm looking at the
car and stuff hmm this sounds so
backwards for me I generally feel like
making sporadic I don't expenditures it
makes me save money I paid the deposit
from a holiday but now you have to say
it now I have say now I need that money
yeah and all of a sudden as soon as I'm
like budgeting I'm not right I need to
pay it off so I'm gonna pay off over the
next few months yeah yeah I just paid
this this this and I'm like okay I've
got that and then after that I'm getting
the car on the car is this X amount mmm
I'm prof I can't afford the car
yeah but when I'm like okay this this
this yeah I'm not profit good I've got
why am I so broke all of that I offer
something every month he's ridiculous I
know he's [ __ ] [ __ ] ridiculous
be a man brother I feel like we didn't
speak I feel like we're not anymore I
don't know what you did for New Year's
that's how much it's not I have no idea
what you do from Christmas tree news I
don't have a [ __ ] clue okay now true
I've seen you what every almost how many
years you're coming up for New Year's
years up here yes or what three three
years yeah yeah I've been about the last
three years and then we probably did we
do stuff together before before you
moved here as I remember probably
probably yeah I realized the other day
so I didn't go out for this New Year's
hmm I've been out for every New Year's
since I've known you since I was 18
years old since since I've been allowed
to go out for New Year's yeah I've been
out every single year buy this one buy
this one
Jesus it didn't even feel on New Year's
must've been a shock to the system bravi
was nice I slept I was in bed I did I
didn't even stay up past midnight
or maybe like I went to bed like just
after midnight I'm a bore I'm old bore
what did you do so few people came here
we had we had some food be chilled for a
bit and a few drinks
they were meant to vixx's for the
countdown SHINee Lee missed because I
got baked and slept for two hours
actually nearly missed it oh my days
then went to suck the club that we tried
to [ __ ] games oh what's the saying so
average really it's like people
pretending to be pretentious so it's not
so it's do you know I mean do not mean
that they've got pretentious clubs and
you got that people pretended yeah yeah
[ __ ] it but that that was just that
was just one day I went day it just
wasn't it wasn't the vibe wasn't there
consider it was New Year's Eve I thought
would be poppin oh I got a connector to
hook me up that's why so I didn't pay
for anything let me go ahead and say it
was fine but it just wasn't why I
expected I mean yeah time that we didn't
get in it makes me I infuriate me if you
ate I never did I know it did but that
was like you could tell it was that
scene in terms of like begging to be
pretend yeah yeah yeah because they were
going above and beyond
to find reasons to not let me here yeah
I just thought what is this which in a
way like they kind of pushed it over the
edge because like in a way it creates
that like air of mystery mmm like [ __ ] I
want to get in like why these why yeah
it's so difficult to get in yeah but
then they almost pushed the boat too far
when this yes try and tell me I'm too
drunk to come in when I hadn't even had
a great drink yeah remember the you're
right you're right you look a bit drunk
babes your tits are out that's what I'm
looking at my gays because you caught me
caught you caught me look in my VC you
saw me saw you and now I'm scared so
that's why I look drunk I'm [ __ ]
SOB's that's funny that's funny but yeah
after that went casino and then came
home and slept mmm [ __ ] slap live man
yeah yeah what did we do last year where
did we go last year last year we did we
were here last year no yeah and this
yeah
yeah last year no we went to panacea oh
[ __ ] I'm step further I went to sunset
they went to panic the odd car yeah
which I should never be allowed to do
[ __ ] yeah went to panacea got a table Oh
God
and after that I've generally felt like
I was the only person drinking I felt
like I had to give me a yeah I thought
we can't take these home I need to get
rid of it loads of all and then I love
chewing gum a girl's head and then he
started vivre and nearly start a fight
for everyone so yeah that was what was
the last year like I forgot about that
yeah bro geez New Year's I build up New
Year's fam I build up New Year's ru I
used to anyway I used to make out like
it's never as its I can't remember a New
Year's dive has ever been as successful
as what my head in thought it was gonna
be I know what you mean I my head is
gonna be the sickest night time I know
I'm for terrorism
yeah man money I know you mean but yeah
the same time if for example New Year's
just gone the other day if someone would
have messaged me like I'll come out like
last minute I probably would have the
best night my life yeah yeah cuz no
plans no spontaneity spontaneous nice
out there's nothing nothing I think we
said that before actually we must have
yeah contain it's nice out are the best
nights I've ever had
all of them like remember yes yeah very
heavy yeah man yeah man yeah man yeah
man
[ __ ] brav 2020 chat to me you I didn't
ask you chat to me about the what did
you think of the Kevin Hart documentary
so that do you know what it was very
insightful
it may mean it made me realize it's not
just a one-man team
like there's so many people not even
behind the shadows like obviously Kevin
Hart is Kevin Hart he's got his brand
it's basically him bun without his
support system he would not be able to
do anything do you know what cut
anything you know what [ __ ] cut me
well you know towards that name oh no
not the plane what so quite a plane all
my days so um yeah if anyone doesn't
know what we're talking about Netflix
Kevin Hart or documentary such series 5
episode documentary or don't [ __ ] this
up called over this art talks at bye
ties in his lows over the last few years
his family and all this it's deep and
that genuinely thought it was gonna be
[ __ ] hmm I thought it was gonna be Kevin
Hart talking about self yeah I can't be
asked for this the stuff he left in
broth I was like are you sure yeah yeah
what man to hate you yeah brother yeah
the bit that cut me it was obviously so
when he was with the whole like
homophobic tweet yeah one like ten years
from ten years ago and he was like right
I'm done saying I'm sorry
mm-hmm it's done and it cetera cetera
cetera if anyone has to me now tell him
to listen to the Ellen f so that I just
did like I'm not talking about it
anymore
and he had the meeting with his team
mm-hm it was like right I just want to
make sure that you guys are with me
obviously this is the stance and stuff
like that and then he's gay exactly like
I knew she was that obviously I'm with
you my friend I would never do this but
I've got a gay wedding planner who won't
speak to me I thought okay partner who's
asking me what's going on I've got a gay
brother who's ringing me asking why am I
staying with you I've got this is a
[ __ ] up my life this is this and this
and this I just want to make sure that
you know why is it what is effective for
the people around you my manhood
gobsmacked yeah my man look God didn't
know what to say I would be gobsmacked
it's same because he doesn't know their
lives outside of what I met he might do
but like he doesn't know the extremities
him is just what their work yeah come in
do you at home like yeah the shit's
happening to him mmm like no one else
just deal with it but he's just like
talking to the team
probably for our debut like yeah all
right Kevin with you and then that's it
the fact without big they start again
emails from my other agencies like you
show you how long it'll work therefore I
want to come over it's mad man one thing
can just set you back for so long
whatever set you back but like make
people judge you cuz obviously he says
that that was ten years ago if you don't
believe that people change the more they
grow then you're a [ __ ] idiot
yeah you can't take my word ten years
ago for grant for for gold or for gospel
and did not think I may think
differently ten years later and he said
he's already apologized since then since
then so when he then apologized yeah
since then he's already done apologized
but the the other bit that got me not
even the plain bear
the other bit that got me was because
you know when you know I was actually
like you know that gif which one of the
black guy from the wire the Toby uses
all the time this one where is that oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah in the shop yeah
yeah yeah that gif was me when obviously
cuz my mind got caught cheating
understand first of all I didn't know
his his boy that boy I knew his boy
recorded it mmm but I didn't know that
the extortion thing cuz I fought because
I know basically the girl tried to sue
him after all of this recently I think
after they filmed this the documentary
the NGO has tried to sue him in it Kevin
Hart saying that him and his boys set it
up okay so his boy he knew his boy that
Jake yeah yeah yeah he newsboys
recording it and wherever it was for his
like own final whatever caught me off
guard so yeah he said it like ah is for
his boy yeah for him in his pleasure on
why his boy he knew his boy was doing it
yes oh she's tried to sue him for it
so these times I didn't actually know
that his boy recorded it and then tried
to extort tell male from him I didn't
know that so 10 million brother in my
head this is the thing in my head all
the extortion aside I was like cool got
caught she in yeah at the end of the day
you're Kevin Hart you're the most famous
comedian on planet earth you're gonna
cheat and you've been cheating
that's just your wife will have to deal
with it like your wife knows what it is
like
I remember thinking like I don't know
why everyone's getting so riled up but
obviously he cheats like is is in it and
yeah got caught destroyed but like we
move yeah she ain't gonna leave him we
move and I thought it can't be that I'm
not trying to like diminish it but like
I was thinking she can't asking if she
can't be surprised yeah and I'm sure the
hardships that she's dealing with and
not that harsh because she knows the
situation that she's in yes knows who
her husband is that wasn't kind of in my
head okay and I thought obviously
they're not gonna get divorced and
they're just gonna
from when I saw obviously that's just my
perspective in my life I'm not slippery
in my life
or in our lives if your girl finds out
you cheated is a problem between you two
and that's just the end of it when she
was walking down to the elevator and the
paparazzi were in her face like have you
spoke to Kevin today where Z is he
coming home is it this and that like how
you feeling brav fro and she's dealing
with that every day
I would bang him all her comments and
Instagram were just people chatting
about it I was like I was like the gif
I'll dealer as I love this is a lot
that's too much to handle it's too much
we're getting divorced
it's pressure we're getting divorced I'm
not dealing with a house pressure she's
a good wife that changed my whole
perspective on the whole situation
really because obviously and she's a
writer because she the whole time when
they were interviewing her she wasn't
violent yeah not once did she say like I
can't believe he did it
or she was not surprised there he [ __ ]
like she was just she never once
mentioned like the betrayal of being
cheated on she just mentioned like when
she said when she ranked him she said
like how could you let this happen
that was were her first worst thing how
could you let this happen not how could
you do this to here how could you let
this happen
like big man I know you're Kevin Hart
and I know you do your thing but for the
love of [ __ ] God how could you let
this happen yeah yeah yeah this is
exactly what we were talking about way
back yeah when I was being a not an
idiot but I was trying to say like I'm
not condoning cheating but if you're
gonna cheat keep it tidy yeah a bit nip
talk but you know the reason why
obviously follow me that following that
I think was in the same episode the
reason why he said he like lost his he
lost his ways cuz he said he didn't have
his boys around it remember he said he's
trying no one was there to back him so
he said he would have gotten us a punish
or something someone would have stopped
him from doing it so he didn't have his
circle wing is I don't know how I don't
know how true that is
I don't know how true that is I think
that's more true than it's not and I
feel like he may have even if he didn't
she he may have also even if he did
still cheat he made he wouldn't
caught yes yes yes yes so yeah I agree
this is we yeah I agree disagree so I
agree in the fact that if his boys were
around they probably wouldn't have let
him pick up a team in a take back to the
tell Vegas take back to the telly like
yeah they would have been like calm on
that pink thing mmm so yeah if you're
gonna cheat like be smart yes he
probably would have got that tap in the
shoulder in terms of what you doing go
to your wife and I do not see he get up
he's getting hot he's Benji that private
jet not at all overnight and was even
Wilder was that I saw a meme on it
wasn't me it was like it was a like a 10
second segment of her her crying and
whatnot 1:12 and it was like I'm still I
would give him two or three chances and
blah blah and there's so unquote - you
said ma'am I still got two more times to
go I was laughing I was laughing it
speak because she said after like the
second or third time you're out no after
the third sent me around he got caught
the first time he's still got two
chances that faves because like it sucks
but I have to rate it because she
understands the reality operation yeah
yeah the other day like when I said like
people try at that real life ain't real
life it's like she understands real life
she understands that she's Kevin Hart's
wife like your husband's going to cheat
on you he gets exquisite [ __ ] dashed at
him left right and center every day like
it's gonna happen so yeah you're smart
to be thinking you've got this chance
and that chance but then if you're
mugging me off constantly then obviously
I'm gonna have yeah yeah but like yeah
brav it was that was mad and then the
plane bit was the most jaw-dropping part
to your boys you know it's maybe like a
girl thing that's that broke me a bit
fam when I saw him at tonight that I was
like nah I've never seen him like that
before
probably one thats thats what i was on
about when i said i can't believe we
left in mmm I'm surprised he didn't tell
him to take that out I like Eddie yeah
he was I gained so much was I lost
respected and immediately regained it
and when I realized like he could've
told them edit out yeah but he was a
[ __ ] it let me know let them know I'm
the room I mr. Davian so for context
people that don't know I've not seen and
yet to watch I don't give a [ __ ] about
watching it this is the context he was
on a private jet
of all these boys he's one of his boys
is just just in here where his name is
his personal trainer so they were flying
somewhere for a show and they start they
were playing cards and in spite having
like a friendly banter conversation in
the nest I turn into an argument saying
Kevin Hart was saying to his trainer if
all of this stop today where would you
be would you be rich would he kept on
asking me do you have a home do you have
a home like the disrespect to tell your
big boy
being a brother like do you have a home
like do you have a as if say I depend on
Kevin Hart both quantities we've Kevin
up all the time but man having clients
beautiful I was fine before you family
finer after you and the thing is yes she
would be even though I don't know his
financial situations in order for him to
even become Kevin Hart's trainer even
myself in doing something like Rev and
he's the CEO of that just train ting mmm
I didn't know that before that just
train things actual a serious thing mmm
like global go really yeah that's brand
is actually global right and then
they're doing alright I've just seen it
I've just seen it as like a typical like
Jim Shaw vanquish yeah JT like I've just
seen that among those I had no idea he
had any affiliation to do with it um but
yeah um he was gun in him he was
guarding him by buff do you even have a
home I couldn't even have a home if you
did all this stuff could you survive
could you survive a mum was like brother
I was firing about you I would find out
that man was literally like they're like
give her why are you doing this like why
are you doing this I mom was still gonna
go he was gonna knock him out yeah
brother I was scared for Kevin when he
got off the plane
we might not got off first and he was
just there ready found one that he's big
very Kevin small so small he will rock
Kevin [ __ ] man he will rock him it's
it's wild bro but obviously that was
after the whole scandal about jay-z
doesn't know to trust good thing is as
well with it with the his boy obviously
trying to extort him in that like that
really really really resonated yeah
because not like any flight that's ever
happened to me yeah yeah I know it's a
pageant like is it sure like you doing
that to me cuz they know Angela 15 years
for 10 yeah it's literally like us
coming out me [ __ ] up and then you
belly me a few days later like I've case
the sitch I've got this darn you give me
10 Miller on each
I'll say from who is this yeah yeah yeah
yeah prove it
ah this is not you open up would you he
must've been thinking what do you mean
yeah yeah we boys fam that is stretchy
you mean cuz I feel like there's nothing
stronger than a bond between boys my
boys boys jaws will always girls have
bones and boys and girls and applause
but there's nothing stronger than a plan
that abondon your boy boys boys [ __ ] you
over that will that change your lines
your aspects on everything think it
actually will you know man we were
talking about like be involved we'll get
home and like the roller coasters of the
ocean fam and I'm always I'm always
backing out girls when they like I've
been hurt before I'm scared and all this
stuff
I was time to shut up that's all yeah
but if I got [ __ ] over by like boy boy
like brother
yeah I wanna you man if I got [ __ ]
over like that then I would literally
have a yeah I wouldn't know what to do
breakdown I would have a breakdown 100%
I wouldn't know what to what to do it's
crazy man it's crazy
yes it's not like you knew that's 15
years brother a long time I don't think
I've known anyone for actually that's
all I've known is over 50 more than 15
years
mmm just [ __ ] a long time bark
but yeah long story short it's a great
watch yeah guys if you haven't watched
it it's only like that between 30 and 45
minutes long this five episodes or six
episodes I think it's five five year I
watch it all in one night is so
addictive it's good it's really good is
something very very different what Kim
has done before obvious there's nothing
it shows his life and it just shows how
much you need a support system around
you like though everything that lets see
obviously Jacob Riis on fire boy he's a
musician
I wouldn't Jacob himself is a brand same
as any other musician is a brand but
there's always gonna be his people
behind any support system or whatnot so
I don't know it's just a good it's a
good insight to their life it actually
is a very good insight their day-to-day
life their celebrity life I love it made
me realize like obviously they're
different there's different levels of
wealth mm-hmm and like obviously is
Richard yeah he's been worth like
he's out here trying to be a billionaire
yeah and it just goes to show like how
[ __ ] hard it would be to become a big
yeah he's trying to do everything
everything everything to chase this
billion everything every day business
after business after business of the
business
always chase and always chasing always
chasing to be a billionaire and you're
like being as long because when you
think like a billion is a thousand
million hmm when you see rich rich
people and like when you do stupid stuff
like I was their net worth and yeah yeah
they're always like 350 million four
hundred million you're like [ __ ] that's
all money you need to double that yeah
you need to [ __ ] that's their whole
life earnings and then make that four
hundred million and even double dies in
over a billion even double that still
not a billion so think how hard it must
be to make a billion ridiculous [ __ ]
geek ulis broth is actually crazy I
couldn't believe it
this is stupid you know obviously
speaking of Kevin Hart when I was
watching that watching the documentary
was thinking about some of the specials
and stuff data's hmm and the skip wing
is on about getting burgled
in the most recent stand-up razón about
getting burglary he's hiding guns around
his yard Rob I was thinking about that
because I was talking to someone about
it the other day and I was thinking like
what's the cool glove compartment yeah
yeah yeah clock compartment that's the
joke glove compartment what like the two
ways I would react if someone tried to
break into my art and like it's funny
because I would react to different ways
depending on how the person who's
breaking in breaks in yeah so I was
laying in my bed not thinking about this
so basically it is a paint a picture for
you I was laying in bed right obviously
is all dark mm and I had not the hallway
light on but their lounge light on so
you could kind of see a little bit of
light mmm and I'm there and I'm in and
my doors like kind of half open I like a
quarter opens a little crack in it and I
remember thinking I was just laying
there thinking about that that sketch
and I was laying there thinking someone
tried to break into my yard right now
what would I do
hmm and then I was thinking about like
someone trying to bust
if I heard the door like open and stuff
like that and then someone's trying to
come in and I imagine like right you
know what I actually think I back it
like I think I'll storm out a [ __ ]
door and just saw swinging yeah and then
I was like yeah yeah yeah actually back
yeah and then I thought what if I was
asleep
hmm and I woke up and saw someone
peeking through the corridor and just
staring at me
same situation someone's still broken in
yeah but they're in and they're just
staring at me sleeping I'm not moving
for sure for sure because I can't
if I were yet if I we had some debts
brough but you're still gonna kill me so
my heart's in my I can feel my my just
beating thinking about I'm getting hot
is but I'll be so [ __ ] scared I'll be
so [ __ ] so I've been visited it now
it's the scariest thing it's this ghost
enough to think of what came out you
just staring that man and he doesn't
know I'm awake yeah and I'm just there
screaming like that you're screwing all
that and you're just there and your
heart pounded I need you and you're
thinking is that someone staring at me
on my dream in oh yeah my just like you
is it a figure it's just a figure oh is
it the coat realize I'm staring at me I
didn't you just hear him like oh my god
it's a scary thing I can think of and
then I thought why is that so different
yeah because I'm not [ __ ] moving yeah
and I'm gonna get killed
yeah because I'll be I'm paralysed to
fit yeah but if anyone's making a ruckus
mm-hmm I'm a Wong see I'm swinging I'm
saying I'm here oh [ __ ] if someone's
Snoopy oh god that's when they staring
creepy like I'm petrified petrified it
could be the same Donny yeah at the same
day it's very different scenario spam
one on my [ __ ] and the other arm I'm
here oh I don't know why I was thinking
about that boss you can please don't
ever let someone creep into my house
that's what I was funny I was terrified
I was at you after that thought I
struggle to get out of that I struggled
against I was [ __ ] scared that's
funny
Bravo I wouldn't know what to do [ __ ]
that's funny I wouldn't know what the
[ __ ] to do [ __ ] horrible that's
hilarious
you said you had something to say to me
yes so this is completely random
absolutely random obviously for those
that actually know us we watch a lot of
anime like bleach video as we speak
abundance of anime and before you lot
start talking especially Bella a Bella's
an advocate of how keep you watching all
these [ __ ] cartoons
call about it okay these times when I
put it on she gets intrigued it starts
watching and starts watching the arms
outside she gets to like it so I spoke
to someone the other day and they asked
me a question and it blew me because I
figured [ __ ] I've watched a lot of anime
I don't know the answer is so she asked
me and I'm asking you now that this is a
direct question cycle of all the enemies
you've ever watched what anime world
would you want to live in and I'm a
world what I want to live in that's a
good question and bear in mind the anime
lovers and anime watches it's not an
easy question to answer
you can't just answer it like that
because you know there are so many
enemies there's so many different types
of worlds you know what I think it would
be it's a tough one because people would
say it's not necessarily an anime hmm
but I put it in there easily avatar last
airbender okay right the whole old ones
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I think I'd
want to live I love the idea that
there's like a nation of firebenders a
nation of earthbenders a nation of war
been as a nation of airbenders like that
like it fascinates me that was ahead of
his time by the way brav it was and it
fascinates me and like I look at it and
think and obviously because there's like
it's rare even in those nations is rare
to become like a bender bender regard
and then when I wear every time I'm
watching it I think I've watched it two
or three times now every someone
watching it I'm not even thinking I want
to be the avatar I'm thinking like if I
just woke if I was born and I'm just an
earthbender I'm gassed I am so [ __ ]
gasps Oh gasps Oh gasps I learn in order
learning different things every day all
day every hour practice all day all day
now stinky broth that's that's the word
for me that's the word for me but yeah
that's a tough one is dear
one so many different ones oh so many
different one love anime [ __ ] that will
be tough broke because then there's
other ones like the Naruto world be
amazed amazing what was that what was
that anime be watched where we fought
before she was gonna be the hardest one
and she died in the first episode and
one remembers caught it was like 12
episodes wow it's like it was cold like
it was in the Sun lessons that you know
exactly I'm Superman is it cool 12
something I remember because it was like
12 assassins were sort of assassins yeah
yeah try it was a price to like stay
alive or sign you out royal kind of
thing and then the landing and then yet
the most arms house one got linked off
for the first episode I was like first
15 minutes and we fought she was gonna
run the thing brav that was sick I wanna
watch that first upset again I Harmon
was called I can't remember but that was
sick Oh
brav yeah there's too many anime if PPA
anyone who you shits on animaker [ __ ]
off it's amazing because a lot of you
would understand it I'm I got asked the
question and my initial response was my
hero
mhm a but then thought if I wake up and
I'm the my mind that constrains
sellotape from his elbows I'm vexed cuz
well if you're born with [ __ ] I'm vexed
you can't change that I'm vexed you know
yes that's your life you can only adapt
to it I'm vexed if that's me but I like
the idea of that world like did you
don't mean from that idea of concept is
sick it depends on a quirk you've got
yes it's hostile world of envy you get
dealt a [ __ ] card and you're just
envious of everyone
then I started thinking of Hunter but
then again mmm
I'd have to find something I'm good at
and then build on that Hunter x Hunter
for those have not watched actually show
everyone what design we had to watch on
to make sense or anyway I love this
there's mother there's actually mad ones
ok cool [ __ ] she Kiki no kyojin I buy
I would shits myself if I was if I was
captain live and Levi's and then if I
couldn't what's the only one I think is
a cool but you're flying pretty a bit of
thing
oh the I comment what they call
something where is it gasps something I
could never do that
I could I could never go batty the first
one I'm out I'm
taking off everything I might I would
launch my left one and it was speed
I'll just launch it here the rest of
them I will look at me now what are you
doing why you waste the gas canisters
always them I'll be so [ __ ] oh [ __ ] in
anime ah boy this yeah boy that I
[ __ ] love I love anime I literally
love I live for I could sit there for
days I have something yeah but days and
days and days I've seen the light of day
I just go and go and go and go go but if
it's actually crazy I [ __ ] love it
I've been watching anime for 10 years
now you have do you know what's weird
say was the Golden Globes or whatever
the other day when that Ricky Gervais is
hosted the Golden Globes Oh every was
and Chinese director or actor I don't
know got an award for the movie parasite
that he did I'm not seeing it but is it
the anime I don't know if it's similar
or any any equivalent to the enemy but
he said something that resonated with me
he said he said it in Chinese and he's
got translator but the translator said
that he said if you open something
similar to like if you open your mind to
the idea of forgetting about the
subtitles
no if you look at if you overlook the
fact that something has got subtitles
you'll open your mind up to so many more
amazing movies or made you know I mean
stuff like that so that made me think of
the people that slate anime the only
reason it they slate is because you have
to reload
perfect example you have to read example
of what you just said understand it
perfect examples get used to it there's
a movie called the hunt mmm and it's got
the guy you know the guy from the bad
guy from Casino Royale and he's dead I
remember he's did you watch the series
Hannibal yes he's in the main Hannibal
the huggable guy basic yeah Norwegian
yeah yeah it's him he's the main
character in a film called the hunt and
that's got subtitles that's in his home
language and whatever and if I'd never
watched anime and if I wasn't so used to
watching subtitles I never never watched
yeah bro the movies [ __ ] amazing
really it's about him he's a nursery
teacher hmm more like a kindergarten
teacher whatever they call it and he's
best for
Dora is one of his like students oh
she's a little kid that goes to the
nursery and her older brothers she's at
home one day and our older brothers are
watching porn mm-hm and she's like three
mmm three or four and they're watching
porn and they're like being [ __ ]
and they like show her that one of the
Prophet shows her the pointers are like
his dick and all this stuff
Shirley's a little girl to the little
girl she doesn't understand any of it
but she loves like she loves the her
nursery teacher the guy she loves him
and one day she goes she's in school
nursery whatever and she said ah can I
have a cuddle and then he's that yeah he
gives her a hug and she said I want to
kiss someone a kiss and he's that
obviously you like my knees but still I
can't kiss you you just explained to our
current case use such etc and she gets
vex so she goes home sits were mom and
dad and then she's just fuming as like a
little kid and then I what's wrong
what's wrong and that she says um was it
the teacher let's call him John
she's like John showed me his dick and
then that dad's like pardon yeah and
then she's like yeah John the teacher
showed me his dick and then everyone's
like what the [ __ ] is she talking yeah
yeah and like that's her dad they're
best friends that that's and the school
teacher our best friend oh [ __ ] so he's
like what are you talking about yeah and
then from the whole thing escalates my
man loses his job my man can't cuz
there's a little tight-knit town so my
man loses his job he gets run out of
church his house gets [ __ ] bricked
like he gets he's walking through the
forest one day someone tries to shoot
him from the whole ting breaks down and
then eventually eventually it all comes
out the whole truth comes out that like
she's like she says like oh I lied he's
like a year later she was like I like he
didn't show me his dick
I asked for a kiss at nursery he said no
I was angry because she's like a year or
two old enough now it was angry he never
showed me his dick the only
nowwhere dick is is because tommy showed
me the born thing like and then the
whole ting like all the investigations
of him stop but everyone still thinks
he's a [ __ ] beautiful
hmm even though none of it happened she
admits to make it up he still gets
treated like [ __ ] from the whole film
ISM it's one of the best movies I've
ever seen and it's all in subtitles and
if I'd never worked out of me I never
would have watched that movie
I'm so [ __ ] grateful that for it for
him because it's one of the best movies
I've ever seen really it's one of the
best movie other sick cloud my advice
about anyone even though just spoil the
whole film I advise the Amy wives
abscess and more I'll give you the ups
and the downs of the whole thing but
still watch it it's amazing [ __ ] it's
amazing I love that movie I'm after
watching was it on net eel no I watched
it on I think I watched it online years
this was years ago I watched us it's not
recent I ended up buying it on DVD for
my mom so there's no F what was a recent
thing mm-hmm
I love I love subtitle movies man it
just opens your mind up to so many
different things there's movies out
there there are movies out there you
assume that if it's not spoken in
English yeah yes movies ridiculous and
that's just us being what's the word I'm
looking for us being small-minded yes
but that's not a word I was thinking for
but long story short small-minded yet
like ignorant or yeah I hate when I've
got a [ __ ] memory block yeah ignorant
that's the word I was looking for
english-speaking people i ignorant I was
gonna suggest English English speaking
people are [ __ ] ignorant yeah he's
mad boy
this [ __ ] movie I wanna watch that
now that you said that
and I want to watch parasite to see if
he's actually anything to do with the
anime parasite cuz anime the anime
parasite amazing [ __ ] it's amazing I
need to watch that game I am watching I
get I am oh my god [ __ ] is amazing it's
dark the arms house enough in that anime
speed speed lemon Anthea your pedaling
rushes in it ah oh my days
enemies the lick and everyone who I've
ever put onto anime mmm gets hooked
no one's ever never told me nah it's not
it's not for me
no one's ever watched a few hands been
on that Anatomy cuz even better like I
said she was sit down and while I'm
watching here she's come back from work
or whatever she what
if you like pop him pop out pop in pop
out but when in his arms how she gets
involved involved and she's like oh my
god oh my god so obviously I RiRi
watching came down a shooter on Netflix
oh yeah and then season 1 episode 6 I'll
never forget there's a guy he's like
quark per se or he's he skill or talent
is to judge and read people's moose yeah
only way he can read people's moves is
by getting a [ __ ] hit so many times
the guy with the bowl cut yeah yeah why
it's the guy in the corridor in the
hotel and he gets a bang they get
spanked but at one time he gets a move
right gassed because you know for a fact
it's coming it's coming
and by the what gasses me the most was
the actual takedown at the end how he
took down to my mind yeah I kind of
explained it I wish I just had a picture
just to show you because the move the
position he put himself in to knock my
my now bro I've bro I not watch episodes
crap was sick I need to what I've said
was genuine Kangana sure on Netflix
watch it season 1 episode 6 that's the
one I'm talking about specifically I
can't remember any of the names but I
just love the fact that every fighter in
that anime has something different about
them oh yeah different type of yeah you
just feel different martial art types
there isn't so many and this sick like
so [ __ ] many when is um I go guess
cuz obviously I do jujitsu mmm the
little blonde kid the young young young
young young one coil still slim one yeah
he does jujitsu from the gutters of the
grapples yeah AFM gasses me
ghastly gas I'm stuck there like [ __ ]
sick oh my days
[ __ ] I love anime saimin as this year
enemy it's the only [ __ ] and he is they
gets me through my Damon even if I work
a longer shift I can watch anime I just
saw I was talking the other day like you
can watch anime the way these Japanese
man first of all Japanese were not
perfect but every anime has a pervert in
it every so don't be surprised or
alarmed
from every
as a pervert in it and every female has
banging tits
banging dull true even yeah it's an
anime um but like you can watch any
anime get into I was watching both I
watched the whole thing there's one is
it on Netflix as well yeah there's one a
Netflix called haikyuu okay I've not
seen above seems about volleyball okay
it's about a high school volleyball team
it's I bang in like three days I bang my
three seasons of it
no really a binding it's sick really
he's [ __ ] sick okay I loved it okay I
loved I went I went straight through if
I miss [ __ ] hair to be fair you like
sport animes in it cuz you're watching a
basketball one not when I say not too
long ago that was a years ago but yeah
yeah what was that one on the comments
and a food one is what you're watching I
remember could occurr no basket was the
basket one and what she wanted was food
was right man the the Kuroko no basket
one was sick
I remember you say cuz I saw one episode
what I saw was that yours obviously I
didn't gauge the context yeah that's the
thing we're enemies was like you can
show someone like one scene and they
blow out I don't get the context
obviously I think it's the stories they
lay from yes the stories like they set
you up from early and like you get so
invested in characters yeah of course so
invested in character so wouldn't they
do something anything yeah just like oh
my god oh my [ __ ] this is the reason
why why I said earlier about the quote
say if you overlook the style of
subtitles you open your mind so many
many movies English writers aren't the
best writers like these Japanese man
know how to write rough like you get so
invested in each character and their
development and everything their life
you feel like you know them 100 and it's
crazy hundred it's crazy to me you done
like any other series or English than
you ever watch because obviously it's
fantasy but you get so in depth with it
bro you do is because as well they're
not afraid to like with anime there's
Rob there's like with Naruto there's
like 700 episodes total and there's a
bag of characters you get invested in
every single one know like you know what
that character would do in any situation
you know everything about it's like a
podcast layer when there's like for
example a driver and has like 1400
episodes I've listened to yeah I know
him yeah me and him a boys me and him
boys yeah invest it invested and there's
no surprise like if I met him tomorrow I
wouldn't come back in below right you
know he's actually a nice guy because I
already know what kind of guy yeah yeah
like that's what I thought that's what I
assumed people think when the list was
like they know how we would react to
things yeah yeah like even though only
like 50 14 15 episodes in like they know
us and that's what like Japanese people
do vannamei they literally don't care
how long it takes like you they'll tell
a story it could take 10 episodes or it
could take 56 episodes they don't care
they'll just go and go and go
Oh amazing
it's making me happy to say best thing
to do if you don't like anime man I
advise you to I just advise you to start
man you hate to stop and start with
something light and healthy so obviously
I got recommended Fox it called again
I got recommended f no that was the
first enema anime I ever watched this
was ten [ __ ] ten years ago and I
still talk about it till today it's one
of the greatest animes have ever watched
so long story short about definitely as
a kid actually explain you explain
better me deafness the Deaf notes like
psychological thriller so it's about
it's they live in a world where anyone
who dies is dictated by what they call a
Shinigami which is like a death call so
they live in heaven and they dictate who
dies and how they die and the way they
do that is they write their name how
they the name of the person and how they
died and the day and the time that they
die and just for fun just for shits and
giggles is definite from heaven or
throws it down to earth which whoever
picks it up if they figure out how to
use it will have the power to just kill
anyone any way they want and obviously
that happens and the guy who finds it
ends up being like one of the smartest
like high school students in Japan mmm
so it's just like a battle of wits
between him and the most like the
world's most famous
as investigator to kind of see who comes
up on top year and obviously there are
rules in which by the definite will work
and you have to know a certain amount of
information about each person before you
can kill them
use another full name you need to know
their full name and stuff like that and
there's just different little plot
twists that make every little thing more
difficult and easy to get caught and
just like the tricks and the double
blinds and the ups and downs and
brothers just the whole mission watch it
again bro the whole thing is on the edge
if you'll see is such it like an
intellectual masterpiece but I love
Death Note so yeah if you're not into if
you think by animes about cartoons and
[ __ ] what's that one because that's
grown that's growing yeah that's that's
ten years ago so think about the [ __ ]
that's good I love Diane I'm a
[ __ ] it I've watched I can't
lift stop in my enemy of watched oh I
got hundreds yeah yeah hundred hundred
percent hundred episodes of hundreds of
different anime hundreds I'll just get
into anything
mmm so whoever animal I was listening or
watching this hit us up with
recommendations never afraid to start
something
get us the [ __ ] up clever [ __ ] clever
always looking I'm always looking for
new something new something good
don't mention like that bait ones
because we've seen it was a cowboy bebop
I'm gonna slap him those day hunter
exons have seen oh say please don't say
inherited I say one piece all of that
we've seen all of them something new
something new something with a good
amount of episodes yeah when to you
that's cuz I need I want a bench I keep
finding new anime but they're really
like there's only they're only six
episodes deep so yeah and it's the week
after week one handle it brav my hero
alright the mini is juicy yeah I'm so
behind on my hair juicy you might as
well wait to the end of the season I'm
enjoy all at once because I'm vexed it's
[ __ ] juicy [ __ ]
I mean oh bravas sick last month was a
busy month for me I've always kind of
made a minute but yeah [ __ ] come on do
you want to wrap it yeah it was a great
I was good man those guys a gray upset